da muss jetzt auf 100 euro geeinigt
würde ich mal gespannt ob ich die auch
kriege aber es ging auf jeden fall recht
entspannt also mal sehen wir dann nicht
vorgestellt
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen weil mein video ja leute ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut heute
mal wieder zum anfang aus dieser
perspektive
ich bin hier in meinem zimmer wir haben
heute was wirklich cooles vor
ich weiß nicht ob ich heute auch schon
das ganze video drehen kann also jetzt
gerade ist noch morgen wir schauen
einfach mal ansonsten muss ich ein
bisschen abwarten
ich erkläre ich allerdings erst mal
worum es geht falls ihr das video von
gestern noch nicht gesehen habt könnt
ihr das nämlich gar nicht wissen und
zwar wie es gestern um ein fake iphone
ich hab mir letztens schon mal ins
bestellt was nicht funktioniert hat dann
habe ich noch 1 bestellt und das habe
ich euch gestern gezeigt und das hat
funktioniert und ich habe mir so ein
kleines neues format überlegt und zwar
möchte ich einfach mal sachen im
internet verkauft und schauen wie viel
ich wirklich für bestimmte dinge
bekommen kann
vielleicht kann man ja sogar plus machen
keine ahnung ich habe mir dafür ganz
einfach ebay kleinanzeigen rausgesucht
ich werde das dann besten und nicht
immer so ein bisschen mit versteckter
kamera film weil der lauf noch echt
komische gestalten um falls ihr diese
ebay kleinanzeigen facebook kennt schaut
euch immer an
es gibt auf jeden fall ein paar leute da
ist der iq jetzt nicht sagen was man so
aber sicherlich auch ganz viele normale
ich bin einfach mal gespannt wir fangen
heute an mit dem fake iphone
ich stelle das gleich mit euch zusammen
bei ebay ein und dann schaue ich einfach
mal was ich für angebote dafür bekomme
ich hab mal geguckt das gibt
deutschlandweit kein anderes feld iphone
und mal sehen wer sich dafür
interessiert am besten natürlich aus
köln damit man sich kurz mal treffen
kann ich hab das ganze für 104 euro
gekauft und wir schauen einfach mal ob
ich diesen preis dafür wieder kriege
vielleicht kriegt sogar ein bisschen
mehr vielleicht kriege ich auch deutlich
weniger
ja also mal sehen wenn ihr das format
feiert last auf jeden fall jetzt schon
mal daumen nach oben da dann gibt es in
zukunft noch mehr teile und wir setzen
uns jetzt mal kurz am pc und stellt das
ganze rein ist gleich leute das hier ist
übrigens das produkt sieht ja von vorne
aus wie ein iphone also ich bin mal
gespannt wie viele leute sich für
interessieren werden auch wenn es
eigentlich der letzte watts ist diese
leute bevor ich das rein stellen kann
muss ich natürlich erst mal kurz
fotografieren ein paar ansehnliche
produkte focus wir haben sogar eine
schutzhülle und eine panzerfaust hier
schreibe ich auch mit rein wenn ihr das
video noch nicht gesehen hat von gestern
wo ich das getestete checkt es auf jeden
fall war
ganz oben in der video beschreibung
verlinkt als von mir dieser sound
das sieht ganz schön im ohr wollen auch
einzige schön von der verpackung sagt
mehr brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht so
jetzt habe ich die fotos rübergezogen
wir geben jetzt mal hier die anzeige auf
von mensch muss kurz vor dem bildschirm
aufnehmen ich habe mir schon account und
hab ich mich irgendwann mal gemacht ich
habe einmal was in meinem leben über
ebay kleinanzeigen verkauft und habe ich
mir schon gedacht junge was ist das
bitte für ein horror
was ich da für leute gemeldet haben das
waren 500 euro gutschein von einem
bestimmten unternehmen bin ich halt
geschenkt bekommen habe und da haben
sich ganz komisch im ml deswegen weiß
schon wie es ungefähr funktioniert wir
geben hier jetzt mal eine anzeige auch
so hier kategorie auswählen elektronik
handy telefon gut was machen wir jetzt
ist ja kein apple noch weitere geräte
und zugehört zustand ist ja eigentlich
neujahr ist neu ich biete
obwohl ja ist neue kommission ich biete
fake iphone iks mit schutzbrille plus
folie so leute jetzt habe ich in die
beschreibung geschrieben ein fake iphone
ex produkt für ausstellungen im ausland
ich will jetzt ein schreiben von wish
zustand neu inklusive ladegerät
kopfhörer face id shooter sie liehen
genau fest die habe ich extra war das
schreiben war groß ist ganz wichtig weil
da interessieren sich an viele für plus
face id noch in titel leute ich hab mich
schon ein bisschen überlegt was möchte
ich dafür haben und ich fange jetzt
einfach mal ganz stumpf ich weiß dass
hat 100 führung gekostet
es gibt aber sicherlich viele leute ich
will natürlich auch kein abziehen keine
frage so aber wenn ich jetzt schon die
möglichkeit habe ich meine ich habe auch
14 euro versand bezahlt ein bisschen
plus zu machen gebe ich einfach mal 125
kommen wir kommen wir sagen 130 euro
verhandlungs basis würde ich nie machen
immer hier schön festpreis jetzt laden
auch die bilder hinzu einmal dass das
dass das vier bilder 134 so rest muss
ich zensieren könnten teil stand da
schon die ganze zeit habe ich früher
gewohnt als jetzt nicht mehr ich wenn
meine art
das gebe ich mal kurz ein hier
telefonnummer gebe ich nicht wieder an
weil dann rufen mich nur sparkurs an
da habe ich keinen bock drauf so nochmal
kurz alles gecheckt mit dem
veröffentlichen eine anzeige klärt bla
bla bla und nach ich kann hier sogar
geld seine anzeige aufgeben anzeige geht
online in zwei minuten also das ganze
ist jetzt online
ich bin mal gespannt ob sich jemand
melden wird wie viele sich melden werden
und wahrscheinlich dass dinge verkauft
bekomme ob ich überhaupt ein verkauf
bekommen aber ich gehe mal davon aus
dass ich von irgendwann findet der
doktorvater ihr könnt ja sehr gerne
jetzt mal die kommentare schreiben was
glaubt ihr wie viel geld werde ich würde
das handy bekommen schreibt in die
kommentare
ich tippe auf ich habe keine an wir
werden sehen und ja ich bin gespannt ich
melde mich und bis gleich für euch bis
gleich mich vielleicht bis über manche
leute direkt mal kurz ein update das
ganze ist jetzt gerade mal fünf minuten
drin und ich habe einfach schon elf
views und eine merkliste also das sind
leute die das praktisch verfolgen
weiterhin keine ahnung was das bringen
soll bei ebay kleinanzeigen aber gut
hier 11 news also recht gut mal schauen
wann die erste nachricht kommt ich melde
mich leute was geht wir haben jetzt
schon ein bisschen später halb sechs ich
habe allerdings in der zeit ein paar
leuten geschrieben also ich hab noch
nicht bekommen ich zeige so muss man
also zunächst mal
es haben schon 103 leute sich das ganz
angeschaut eine merkliste immer noch
keine ahnung aber ist ja egal da habe
ich zum beispiel mit dieser person
geschrieben hallo noch zu haben ja noch
zu haben ich lese einmal vor weil ich
habe keinen bock das jetzt immer hier zu
zensieren
nein das iphone
super wäre preis etwas zu machen dann
habe ich geschrieben könnten uns auf 100
einigen der welt hat mir geschrieben
hätte interesse was ist letzte preis was
ist letzte preis habe ich geschrieben
könnten uns auf 110 einigen das ding ist
nämlich ich habe das angebot noch mal
angepasst auf 120 euro aus folgendem
grund wenn man hier runter scrollt hier
haben viele leute iphone
angegeben zb der hier iphone 6 s 64 gb
austausch gegen iphone 5 ist warum auch
immer man sein sechs erst gegen 1 5 s
tausch für 120 euro und mainz sagte aber
130 oder doch ihr so ok na ja wir haben
leute geschrieben
ich habe mit dem einen ersten drittel
ausgemacht für 19 uhr wollte ja mal
sehen was da für eine person kommt aber
es freut mich natürlich dass das
anscheinend geht also leute werden jetzt
nur ich treffe mich wir haben hier so
bahnstationen also halt nur normale s
bahn haltestelle kommt da irgendwie hin
und sagen ich hier ist einfach los hier
ist das iphone und ich hoffe er ist
damit ordnung zufrieden
das jetzt auf 100 euro geeinigt wenn ich
mal gespannt ob ich die aufträge aber es
ging auf jeden fall recht entspannt also
mal sehen wir dann gleich traum gesteht
let's go ich finde es übrigens heimlich
mit dieser gopro hier die kann man gut
hier reinstecken oder was auch immer man
sich gleich mal gucken wie ich das mache
also los geht's
[Applaus]
ein
also hier ist es
du hast ließ
ich mache so internet blogs und freund
hat mir das also das halt android aber
sieht heute aus wie ein iphone so einmal
also facebook ans damit machen
wien
wie zum beispiel sowohl muss sich also
dann irgendwie kaputt geht dann kann
sich melden so aber ich habe es nur
einmal benutzt zum festen halt und
[Musik]
ja
besonders wichtig
also darf er eigentlich 120
sie picken
also leute was geht ich will jetzt
wieder zu hause und hier ist mein geld
also ich habe jetzt wirklich hier 50 60
80 und 100 also war entspannt habe ich
mir schwieriger volksnäher also wo ich
schon mal da diesen gutschein verkauft
hat echt ewig gedauert bis ich jemanden
hatte wo ich gesagt hat okay das liegt
jetzt wirklich einigermaßen seriös ich
will einfach nur dass er mir das geld
gibt man das produkte und fertig so
sollte aber laufen aber echt cool also
ich meine ich habe es heute morgen
spontan reingestellt und heute abend
wirklich um 100 euro reicher
beziehungsweise haben einen 100 euro für
das produkt wieder eigentlich wollte 120
jahren ich habe jetzt wir haben uns auf
100 geeinigt dass wenn ich voll okay
eigentlich gehe ich mal sogar davon aus
für 120 sowas weg zu bekommen ist dann
doch eher schwierig was ich aber
trotzdem noch sagen wollte vor allem
eine jüngere kommt jetzt nicht auf die
idee der sachen reise stellen euch mit
irgendwelchen menschen zu treffen das
wollte ich auf jeden fall noch hier
sagen weil sich da so wie ich glaube
oder meiner meinung nach nicht nur
seriöse menschen aufhalten nimmt am
besten immer irgendwie ein mit oder so
wenn jetzt noch jünger sein ansonsten
hoffe ich das video hat euch bis hierhin
gefallen wenn ihr sagt mache auf jeden
fall noch eine folge davon wo du
irgendwas verkaufs keine ahnung man
könnte ja sowieso mal sagen dass man
sich praktisch irgendwelche sachen kauft
die vielleicht so ein bisschen
aufpäppelt und dann wieder verkauft und
schaut wie viel geld man damit machen
kann einfach mal so spontan als format
idee weil ich ja sowieso in zukunft mehr
mit einfach so produkt macht mir spaß
irgendwie so verkaufen sachen auspacken
weiß nicht da gibt gerne daumen nach
oben schreibt in die kommentare was
machen könne
oder treibt es mit einem fenster wurden
30 alex wie wir sehen uns ansonsten
morgen wieder und gibt es ein wirklich
cooles neues video zusammen mit marie
haben wir auch net produkte getestet
oder also leute danke fürs zuschauen und
wir sehen uns morgen wieder haut rein